vous l'adorez c'est jeff panne à coke et
bien sûr à l'action
à l'époque tu débuté dans le spectacle
était très proche de quelqu'un qui
débute également
ouais c'est vrai nom mais ya pas de
vanne fait et quand tu n'as pas vu
depuis longtemps
je sais que tu regrettes quelqu'un avec
qui tu a écumé les gabarits tiendrait
pas est ce que tu sais qui je pense n'a
pas du tout non tu sais pas d'où tu
aimerais revoir de mec qui est avec toi
en cabaret tous à sa mère je parle c'est
vraiment c'est on cerne et ton cerveau
ah bon ouais là comme ça je vois pas il
veut juste se souvenir que faire un
bisou parce que je sais que ça va te
faire vraiment plaisir
il avec nous ce soir c'est pas une
connerie c'est fabien olicard et
[Applaudissements]
tatata l'olympia c'est complet depuis
aujourd'hui on veut exactement 1 fabien
qu'à l'olympia aussi et je sais que
c'est on kiffe absolue fabien tu étais
alors on a fait tellement de merde
ensemble réussi à faire un spectacle
pour enfants à tahiti est bas mais bon
voilà on voulait qu'ils viennent de
faire un petit moment déjà fait jour
marque la torre fait dans sa question
non il n'y a pas mélange garçons c'est
une non moi je suis partie en vacances
avec jean phi encore oui et on en avait
parlé avant que tout ça ça ça sort
temmar a toujours dit qu'ils étaient
très contentes danse avec une femme
et donc j'ai parlé avec lui par texto à
jamais mon petit jean pigeon scène ne
vint jamais mené on a tous voila donc
voilà j'ai discuté avec lui il m'a dit
oui c'était juste une vanne et puis
après ça s'enflamme
en fait ce qui est pire c'est la réponse
de thé ben oui ça va faire avec ces
shows oui il m'a baisé elle c'est drôle
parce que tu es bon tu dis ça mais si
c'est pas un problème d'abord pourquoi
ils n'ont jamais fait comme si c'était
naturel déjà les plus en plus attention
à sa belle voici la première question tu
devais pas la clope c'est parti quel est
le vrai nom de famille de jeff kolka map
cole sofa au col clic-clac allez vous
avez trois secondes vont répondre simon
répondait pas au bout de trois secondes
s'il a les dirigeants moi j'en sais
[ __ ] rien alors vous avez mis quoi
lasser est ce que c'est bon 3 secondes
non non c'est pas bon alors
isabelle vous êtes éliminés cette
élimination vous attends attends tu
t'appelles tu t'appelles colcanap en
fait c'est le passé le verlan et oui
exactement à tout simplement tard à
chercher bien loin non mais c'est vrai
en fait tu t'appelles vraiment jesse non
plus tu t'appelles comment faire la
totale le gars a fait appel padgett tu
t'appelles folle c'est quoi ton prénom
satin sandrine voilà donc c'est
compliqué c'est vrai nom et pourquoi
taper sur marc jean marc et pourquoi pas
tarder à me faire chier toi j'ai pas de
réponse à ta question
merci très bien donc son nom de famille
c'est colcanap ça s'appelle ça s'appelle
un ana cycliques en verlan fait c'est un
âne acyclique je suis toujours de leur
moi je veux de leurs mollets et est
reparti sous quels métiers exercés dans
ses acquis ah oui c'est révéler quels
métiers exercés jet pana coque avant de
devenir un artiste je sais c'est long
billet plombiers électriciens ou
proctologue électricien bas nout mettez
le à l'invite électricien benhaim oui
benhaim si vous avez répondu ou
choisissent équipe j'élimine mathieu
d'accord t'as bien c'est donc attention
va voir si c'est vous ou mathieu inédit
au centre on craint la gueule version se
calme avec mathieu
attends donc mathieu vous activer les
bons bateaux là ça va si mal à vous avez
dominé par les dix ans beaucoup changé
des règles vont changer les règles au
pas changer les règles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n'attendez pas du coup j'ai pas été très
très viril sur la réaction
2 vous avez un bac pro électricien ouais
c'est ouf un ami vous avez commencé à
faire d'électricité oui j'ai commencé
mais il atteint terminé 1 500 vous avez
travaillé chez dell j'ai travaillé sur
les chantiers chez les clients
d'installer des caméras de surveillance
aussi c'est ouf
ouais et pas jean-marc à l'époque à la
[ __ ] moi très bien merci journal
attention question c'est pour ces partis
c'est pour théo théo lorsqu'il avait
neuf ans jeff a participé à une émission
de télévision l'appel je passe à la télé
l'école des fans ou faites entrer
l'accusé qui avait alors j'hésite et moi
c'est pas les notations à merde
arrivé de nantes école des fans qu'elle
dépanneraient
des eaux est ce que c'est la bonne
réponse monter aux éau la télé il est
monté sur scène jeff pana club pour
reprendre du balavoine dans l'émission
je passe à la télé il ya repris mon fils
ma bataille on a la vidéo regardez on
reconnaît déjà très bien il fallait
guérir
regardez pas c'est que c'est magnifique
ça regardez où nous a pas fait c'est
quoi mon fils ma bataille de daniel bahr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais tout casser
si vous touchez
pour lui deux maisons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et tu t'es clashé avec mimie mathy et 9
du tout ce que cette histoire en fait
c'est sûr aux [ __ ] on a mis à
raconter de faux histoire on s'entend
mal on s'engueule et voilà on ce clash
selon vsd jess devait écrire un sketch
pour l'ouverture du show des [ __ ]
qu'il doit interpréter une mini mathy et
bien sûr mimie mathy a démenti sur
twitter est accusée vld d'être un
magazine merdique
voilà un nom mais c'est alors d'ailleurs
je crois qu'on a un extrait de jets dans
le spectacle des [ __ ] et là il me
mettre derrière attention si on passe la
vidéo ça coûte 2000 euros on n'a donc
pas d'extrait s'en sont aperçus qu'ils
n'ont pas cette vidéo 5 août 2011 à
l'épaule et là c'est d'abord précisé